we'd like to consider velocity-dependent
resistive forces so let's imagine a
situation where we have an object and
it's falling in a gravitational field so
we have a gravitational force and this
object is like a marble falling in a vat
of oil and there is a velocity dependent
resistive force that is acting on this
object and let's again choose a positive
direction down and now for objects that
are moving very slowly in a fluid let's
make a model for our velocity dependent
resistive force will assume that the
resistive force is proportional to the
velocity
it's opposing the direction of motion
and we'll put a coefficient alpha in
front and this is our model for velocity
dependent resistive forces for objects
that are moving very slowly for our case
let's consider the units of the
coefficient alpha so the units of alpha
have the units of force divided by
velocity so the units of force are we
have the units of force divided by the
units of velocity and that gives us
kilogram meter per second squared
divided by the units of velocity which
are velocity per second and so we see
that the coefficient of alpha has the
units of kilogram per inverse second now
now what we'd like to do is apply
Newton's second law so let's analyze the
forces and get the equation of motion
for this object falling in a viscous
medium with a resistive force in the J
hat direction we have the gravitational
force and we have our resistive friction
force which we're writing V Y as the Y
component of the velocity and that's
equal to M times DV Y DT now notice that
the acceleration we're not treating as a
constant it's a the derivative of the
velocity this leads us to our
differential equation which is written
as dy DT I'll divide through by M G
minus alpha over m dy
now this is a linear linear and velocity
first-order differential equation with a
constant term in here which is called in
homogeneous linear first order
differential equation we shall solve
this like we did with our other
equations by separation of variables so
what we do is we bring the velocity
terms to one side and the time terms to
the other side and now we can integrate
both sides directly but before I
integrate this side I'd like to rewrite
it by writing it as DV y and I'd like to
pull out a minus alpha over m and this
term here becomes minus mg over alpha
why did I do this for the integration it
just makes my natural logarithm integral
look a little bit easier and over here I
have DT now what I want to do is
integrate and we're going to integrate
from some initial velocity which we're
going to take to be zero we're gonna
drop this let this object be released
from rest and we're gonna integrate to
some final speed V Y of T over here
let's just call our integration variable
T Prime and we integrate T Prime from
zero to some time T so this is our
variable and the velocity is a function
of time now doing this integral first
off this constant term comes out so we
have 1 over minus alpha over m and the
integral is just a natural log integral
of V Y minus mg over alpha and we have
to divide that in the lower limit V Y is
0 and we have just minus mg over alpha
and this side is very simply T now we
can rewrite this equation by bringing
the M over alpha to the other side and
we have log of V y minus mg alpha over
minus mg alpha equals minus alpha M T
now recall that e to the log of any
quantity X is equal to X so if i
exponentiate both sides
I get B Y minus mg over alpha divided by
minus mg alpha is equal to the
exponential e to the minus alpha M T now
the last step is simply to bring this
over there multiply and do a little bit
of algebra and so I get that the
velocity as a function of y is equal to
mg alpha times 1 minus e to the minus
alpha M T now there's a few interesting
things here that we want to look at
suppose we define this exponential e to
the minus alpha MT as equal to e to the
minus T over tau where tau is M over
alpha the units of tau when we look at
the units it has a units of mass which
is kilograms over the units of alpha
which we worked out before so we have
kilograms over kilogram inverse second
that gives us units of seconds and
that's what we expect because T seconds
over seconds gives us a dimensionless
quantity for the exponential now the
last thing we'd like to look at is let's
just see what happens
when we plot this well if we're plotting
B y as a function of T we start off at
zero and we're going to reach some
terminal quantity V Y terminal which is
when we have a graph like that and we
can see what that terminal speed is when
we set t equal to infinity e to the
minus infinity is zero and so this
terminal speed is equal to just this
coefficient mg over alpha and that's the
terminal speed now notice that as a
check for what we did we can come back
to our differential equation and what
does terminal speed mean notice that
when you get to this limit as T
approaches infinity
the slope of the velocity curve is zero
and that's really the statement over
here that the Y terminal is when the
velocity is no longer changing in time
you can see it graphically and this is
the statement when we go back to
Newton's second law that there's
acceleration is zero so the sum of the
forces at terminal speed are zero the
resistive force is equal to the
gravitational force and so from this
equation here as a check we can see that
V y terminal equals mg over alpha which
checks with our calculation and so we
have confidence that we analyzed this
correctly and that gives us our motion
one last thing that's quite interesting
notice that the terminal speed depends
on mass this coefficient alpha is only a
function of the properties of the object
the size the shape the geometric
properties of the object not how dense
it is so if you have two objects like
two balls same radius but one was denser
than the other then the other one mass
would be heavier and the terminal speed
would be greater so what we see is that
two identical objects one heavier than
the other
the heavier object reaches a faster
terminal speed than the lighter object
which explains a well observed phenomena